und sie melden uns hier quasi vom
gefrierpunkt vor dem reichstagsgebäude
die wahl der wahlgang läuft ich habe
jetzt einen gast der zwar nicht mitglied
der bundesversammlung ist aber verdient
als heute ein ganz wichtiger tag ist
nämlich max otte der kandidat der afg
für die bundespräsidentenwahl heute sind
sie eigentlich mit sich im reinen
sie haben politische fahnenflucht aus
ihrer partei begangen sie haben sich von
einem politischen gegner aufstellen
lassen sie werden alle
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht ins schloss
bellevue einziehen und fliegen in
einigen wochen aus der cdu heraus was
das wert naja das mit dem rausfliegen
dass wir mal sehen dass mit der
fahnenflucht sich anders ich glaube ich
habe meiner parteien dienst erwiesen sie
hat es nicht geschafft einen eigenen
kandidaten aufzustellen dieses amt ist
überparteilich da sollte auch das
gedanke an parteipolitik jetzt mal
wirklich ruhen ich glaube man könnte
anders mit dem amt umgehen ist die frage
ob die person als solche für dieses amt
qualifiziert ist wer in ein sich passiv
vorschlägen vor schlagen lässt und eine
nominierung annimmt
das ist für mich nicht parteipolitik
sondern es geht um das höchste staatsamt
sagen ja sie sind im prinzip dagegen
kandidat aus dem bürgerlichen lager der
kandidat eigentlich eher unionsparteien
obwohl die ja den bisherigen präsidenten
unterstützen was hat sie an der
amtsführung von frank walter steinmeier
gestört dass sie jetzt gegen ihn
antreten also ich glaube schon das land
ist weiter auseinandergedriftet ich weiß
nicht wie viel er noch hätte tun können
hat natürlich seinen abend ausgefüllt
aber ich glaube er hätte noch mehr zur
versöhnung beitragen können noch mehr
tatsächlich den dialog fördern können
das ist der job eines bundespräsidenten
das macht er aber ich glaube man hätte
mehr tun können und man sollte zu ihrem
verhalten sie haben ja cdu delegierte
aufgefordert sie zu wählen hier bei der
bundestagswahl bei der bundesversammlung
die lernen ja eigentlich in dem kleiner
sagt gepunktet wenn sie das täten denn
damit wird der neue vorsitzende
beschädigt wenn jetzt jemand gewählt
wird in die ein politischer gegner ich
sage es noch mal aufgestellt hat glauben
sie wirklich dass das im großen umfang
passiert prognosen sind sehr schwer aber
in der tat ist natürlich da viel
parteipolitik drin aber ich sehe es
außerhalb der parteipolitik ich bin
parteifreund noch ich hoffe ich bleibe
ist aber das wird sich zeigen und ich
sehe mich als durch und durch bürgerlich
an und von daher glaube ich wäre es eine
echte alternative gewesen dass jetzt im
klein-klein der tagespolitik
wahrscheinlich da er weniger stimmen
kommen das denke ich schon aber trotzdem
was dann gehst du dich mehr wert ist und
auch ein das hat ja auch viele
persönliche abfahren und durchaus
nachteile dass man sich aufstellen lässt
gerade in diesem falle und ich denke es
ist ein signal für die demokratie jetzt
haben sie trotzdem gegen die interessen
eigentlich ihrer partei gehandelt wenn
man das so sieht war das irgendwie
anders vorstelle es denn denkbar dass
zum beispiel ein ingenieur von mercedes
benz auf offener bühne ganz offen autos
für bmw entwickelt dass sie sich eben
von der asd da haben vereinnahmen lassen
so ich sehe es eben nicht so dass ich
gegen die interessen meiner partei
gehandelt habe sondern ich glaube sie
hätte einen gegenkandidaten aufstellen
müssen ich habe ja auch mal gesagt wenn
sie noch einen gegenkandidaten
aufstellen dann trete ich von der
kandidatur zurück und das andere ist das
natürlich die interessen unseres landes
die interessen unseres landes
deutschlands über den interessen der
partei stehen genauso wie der
bundespräsident über parteien steht da
ich keine karriere in der partei
anstrebe war mir dieses übergeordnete
interesse wichtiger wenn wir diesen weg
der dahinter uns ist zwei kilometer in
diese richtung gehen dann käme man am
schloss bellevue vorbei am amtssitz des
bundespräsidenten da werden sie
allerdings wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht
einziehen sie haben gesagt sie wollen
danach sozusagen ihre parteipolitische
karriere beenden bleibt es dann auch
dabei ja natürlich ich habe ja nie in
dem sich eine parteipolitische karriere
gehabt ich habe ein halbes jahr
vorsitzender der reunion das ist ein
ehrenamt das ist ja auch kein profi job
das sind mit viel arbeit verbunden
ich bin polizist ich bin unternehmer ich
bin analytiker und dass wir die
weitermachen eigentlich wollten wir
nicht wetten und irgendwelche tipps
abgeben 151 delegierte hat die af die
wiese stellen werden sie bekommen also
es gibt einige ausfälle kroner bedingt
ich glaub's für 135 sind da ich würde
mich freuen wenn ein paar mehr kommen
aber das ist alles sehr sehr schwer
voraussagen soweit max otte der afg
kandidat in der bundesversammlung zur
wahl des bundespräsidenten bedanke mich
dass sie da war und wir gehen ganz
schnell sogar die auch in von verloren